As one final explanation for this lesson, let's see if there's a different
inequality we can look at that can give us this same solution set. I'm just
quickly going to rewrite the original inequality that we have, and see if I can
modify it to simplify it a little bit. One thing I'd like you to notice, is that
this negative sign outside of the entire expression, is going to effectively
multiply either both terms in the numerator by negative 1 or multiply the entire
denominator by negative 1. So, we can consider this a common factor of, for
example, both terms in the numerator. There's one more common factor within one
of the quantities here, and that's 2, in the quantity 2x minus 4. Both 2x and
negative 4 are divisible by 2. Let's rewrite this. Because multiplication is
commutative, I can move these factors around however I want. And I think what
I'd like to do is to write this factor of negative 1 half, as a single constant
outside of the rest of the terms multiplying that fraction. Now, we can very
clearly see that there's this factor out here, this constant factor, that we can
just divide both sides by to get rid of. However, since we will be dividing by a
fraction, we can equivalently just multiply it by its reciprocal or multiply by
negative 2, on both sides, of course. Now, here's the kicker. Remember, that
since we're multiplying by a negative number on both sides, we need to switch
the direction of the inequality. So now, we have this new inequality, x plus 10
over the quantity x plus 2 times the quantity x minus 2 is less than 0. And in
fact, if you went through the entire process of solving for x here, you'd find
that the solution set for this inequality is exactly the same as the solution
set for this inequality up here. And we can tell why that's the case. These are
equivalent. We move from this one to this one using completely legal algebraic
modifications. Let's see how graphs can help us understand this inequality a
little bit better.